more severe weather is slowing rescue
and relief efforts in Indonesia four
days after a devastating tsunami killed
more than 420 people this morning
officials are warning people to stay
more than a mile away from the shoreline
imagine that they're afraid of another
giant wave we've got Barry Peterson
forests in London following this story
Barry good morning good morning well
what has been hard has now gotten harder
heavy rains mean trucks with relief
supplies can't get through muddy roads
machinery can't dig into the debris and
it's worse for the homeless and the
frightened so it's about keeping spirits
up like getting the little kids singing
and smiling shelters are overflowing
with 21,000 people evacuated as a
precaution against another tsunami
mostly the old and the young like
eleven-year-old poopit I'm too afraid to
stay in my house she says and as the
massive scope of the cleanup becomes
clear drones are just now showing the
devastation in more remote areas as the
hunt goes on for survivors or bodies it
was on this day in 2004 that an
earthquake triggered tsunami roared
across the Indian Ocean killing some
230,000 120,000 of those in Indonesia
after that Indonesia built a major
earthquake alert system but officials
now admit the system stopped working in
2012 because of lack of maintenance
it may not have mattered since this
tsunami was likely triggered by a
landslide caused by this volcano
has been erupting for months and still
is which means there is still the danger
of another tsunami
that's why nerves are so very much on
edge and why reports of another tsunami
sent panicked
searchers running away from the shore
yelling water is coming so far the
reports have all been false alarms there
is some relief in sight the high tides
begin easing today and that means if
there is another tsunami it may not have
the blunt force power of the one that
hit over the weekend Adriano Barry thank
you